[Music]
Oh
it is not easy to steal scenes from
towering transformers and too hot
leading men Mark Wahlberg is Josh
Duhamel but that is just how amazing
fifteen-year-old Isabella moon air is in
the last night and our karlie still join
us Valentin Chicago actually get ready
for their big premiere tonight fight
like a girl yeah I felt like your girl
coming with me or what you have been a
Little Miss globe-trotting jetsetter
you've been everywhere Shanghai even to
China you've been to London we're gonna
go to Brazil we're gonna go to Miami are
you loving being on this tour are you
kind of ready to get home and relax a
little well I mean ow I always want to
be home I'm a homebody but you know this
is a great opportunity I've been
following your fashion choices you've
done long hair you've done short hair
what's the vibra gonna see tonight I
don't know I think I think since I just
got a little fresh new haircut I'm gonna
rock this one I was just a normal kid
for my world fell apart
Isabella's world in real life as a
normal kid is probably no more thanks to
all the transformers excitement pretty
sensational for the Cleveland native who
turns 16 next month how are you planning
to celebrate your 16th birthday
hopefully relaxing the opposite of what
usually 16 year olds are doing at their
birthday parties um you know I kind of
want to just relax and sleep a whole
entire day do you hope you're gonna get
a car gift from Mark Wahlberg and mostly
just thinking about the cars that
Michael Bay has on say is too many and I
was hoping that he'd be able to give me
one mine air shows a lot of
self-assurance in the movie too
[Music]
I'm afraid
and at 15 Isabella had already been
accepted to college you know I was able
to do my homework too and graduate with
all straight A's and skipped two grades
I mean I think I did all right
[Music]
you